welcome to pi data global 2021 and the
triple thanks to
to adam for being a speaker here and
since it is time i'll let him take over
okay thank you very much
um
okay so uh yeah today i'm going to be
talking about um how we go about
building data-driven products um at
pre-under
um
and i'm a data scientist myself so i'll
be talking about it from uh the
perspective of a data scientist uh i'm
sure there are various aspects of
product development that uh are yeah not
related to data science at all which i
won't be touching on uh so the data
centric aspects of it um and yeah i'll
just get started
okay so um only got 25 minutes so it's a
fairly simple plan
um first of all a few introductions just
so you know who i am and who the company
is um leonda
um
and then i'll introduce the idea that
we're currently developing or hoping
will become a product um
a little bit about our tech stack
which is obviously gonna dictate a
little bit how we go about things
um and then uh finally uh i'll walk
through the timeline of a development um
so again using this uh
current example um as a um to walk
through
um
okay so um first of all um
yeah who are we um my background
personally is in particle physics um i
joined uh plunder after doing my phd
back in 2014
um and the company
at the times a small german company had
a similar background so it was founded
by a particle physics professor um who
saw a good opportunity to apply
statistical methods um from particle
physics into real-world business
problems
um and he also had a good pool of phd
students to
hire as his first people to bring into
the company
and so it's a very easy transition
for me personally to we've been to the
company for that reason um
it was uh yeah unusual in that it had
more than half of the company was made
up of uh you know phd students or old
phd students who moved into business
um
and the
idea of um
behind the company was basically to
um go to uh
go find customers get them to send us
their data and just see if we could
predict something useful from it
um
so we had no product development um
background we're just basically a bunch
of nerds who for let's see if we can
um
do something a bit differently to how
it's been done in this industry before
um
and so uh we had some success with that
eventually we had a few customers um but
very bespoke solutions for those
customers uh and realized that in order
to scale uh we're gonna need to uh start
productizing um what it is we do
um
and after numerous years lots of
failures a very inefficient
route to it
we had a few um quite uh
well um
developed products so uh demand
forecasting products around some around
order optimization um some for price
optimization this was kind of our sweet
spot
um
and uh
at that point we were acquired by jda in
2018
who had solutions um much more across
the full supply chain so they went back
into transportation logistics warehouse
management all kinds of stuff like this
um and blue under then renamed
themselves uh sorry jda who who acquired
beyond then renamed themselves to
blyonda
um so a bit of a confusing uh
um acquisition and renaming uh but yeah
i'm of old beyond and new blender now so
um
and then finally from an introductions
perspective um yeah what are the main
steps that that i think of when we're
talking about moving towards a product
um so first of all we need to identify a
business problem
um we need to think of some way to solve
that problem
and then we need to see if our solution
works so do some feasibility checks
proof of concept proof of values
and finally generalize it and so that's
the uh yeah the steps which i'll be
walking through a specific example today
um
okay on to uh yeah the first of those so
what's the business problem
um
that i'll be talking about today
uh it is about poor inventory accuracy
so if you think of a large supermarket a
grocer
um they have tens of thousands of
products and hundreds of stores
and over time their inventory just
becomes inaccurate
and this is costly to them
so the quote here from their study is
that about 60 of inventory records are
likely to be wrong at any point in time
and they estimate that um this uh
if they're corrected then you could
achieve uh four to eight percent
increase in sales um so a significant
problem um with a
good price to go after um so that ticks
our box number one what's what's a
business problem
um what's the cost associated to this
problem um so
you can lose sales because you don't
realize you're out of stock of something
um you can
uh
not be able to satisfy online orders
because you don't have the uh you don't
know if you've got the stock for it or
even worse you accept an order that you
can't fulfill um
there's lots of manual effort around
counting the inventory so going uh into
the warehouses onto the shop floor
counting everything
and lots of retailers just carry uh what
they call just in case inventory so
they'll just add some number to their
stocks of everything um just in case uh
and this obviously can lead to higher
waste for uh items with a shorter shelf
life um
and also leads to uh having more money
tied up in capital as well to have that
stock
um
yeah there must be some solutions out
there for this already you might be
thinking um so what are they
um one
solution is just account more frequently
so this is costly it's very manual
and it's disruptive to store operations
as well
um having people out there
blocking the shoppers
you can have hardware robotics imaging
um is just quite expensive and hasn't
been so successful in the past
um and you can as i mentioned for carry
access inventory which is in itself
costly
um so what is our idea
um
yeah with our background in machine
learning what we thought to do is just
simply treat it as a machine learning
problem um and predict the actual
inventory um so treat the inventory as a
variable that we can um
we can estimate
um and so what we'll do is look at uh
every single product location at a
specific time and try and predict its
inventory
um so as with any machine learning
problem we've got a few data
requirements um we need to have some
suitable history in the data
so that means accurate knowledge of
previous inventory errors so
we have to know at the point in time
exactly what the inventory was and how
wrong it was how much it was wrong by so
every time somebody did a count
physically in a store
um you will have a data point uh if they
recorded that correctly
and finally we obviously need to have
some data that correlates to that error
so we need something to to construct
features with um
um
and does this make sense as a product so
there's a problem we've got an idea
is this just a project for for one
customer or bespoke solution or is this
really something we want to pursue as a
product
um
so if it were successful uh it would
solve a problem that we hear again and
again from customers
and so this is uh something which um
yeah isn't just one or two of our
customers are saying they've got this is
a problem most of them uh say that this
is a significant issue
um
and the nice thing about it is that we
are
looking to correct a fairly fundamental
data point in a customer system
and from a supply chain perspective lots
of things feed downstream of what the
current inventory is
so
one thing it can feed into is a
replenishment system so you might want
to just improve the accuracy of
inventory and get better replenishment
as a result
um but but there's anything else that
uses the inventory would would benefit
from this so
um like i mentioned before online
ordering um
promising uh customers that the stock
will be there for example
uh these sorts of things it also uh
feeds down to
it plays very nicely with our other
existing products i mentioned a few of
our products that beyond already um
around demand forecasting uh order
optimization uh this would just
supplement those as to make them better
um
by improving this variable
and compared to robotics and uh lots
more hiring and so on it's a simple
thing to improvement so the data already
exists it's just us um building a model
and
embedding this process uh within their
existing systems
um
okay sometimes i get a bit lost in a uh
talk when people are moving quickly
through slides so i thought just to take
a pause for a second and be very very
clear what i mean about our machine
learning target
um so the goal is to improve accuracy um
but for uh an algorithm to do that we
need to be able to quantify it so a
couple of terms first of all um counted
inventory this is the result of a
physical counting process so a man goes
to a shelf and counts one apple um
that's a countered inventory
and at the same point in time when when
you count the apple you can look up on
the system what the inventory is
and there are three items there
and so this defines our target it's just
the difference between the two of them
we know that the inventory was -2 at
that particular point in time and so
that serves um
that becomes one row of our training set
um
okay so we've got an idea uh we've got a
problem we've got an idea um and uh so
what do we do next
um
so we give it a name
uh it's called illumina cognitive
inventory um
something which uh the marketing people
come up with
um and how do we start
uh first of all
so this is our blue yonder strategy i'm
sure there's many ways to go about this
this is how we go about it today i'm
also not saying this is the only way um
but it's a way that we found some
success um
uh so you find a customer
um
we've got a customer um i can't say
their name right now because it's an
ongoing thing but there's a large
retailer who's very keen
to do this and having a real customer
right from the get-go uh is is hugely
beneficial so they've got all the domain
uh knowledge about what the problem
really means
um and then we've got real data um to
test it on this is this is invaluable
i've seen quite a few times people
develop very interesting things but but
then you go out and look for a customer
and you know customers don't necessarily
want what you've built so you've already
solved one problem if you start off with
something they say they want
and
then
what do we do next we build a team um so
actually
different companies will go about this
in different ways i'll talk a little bit
more about this point next so we start
off we need to build a team
then we uh prove the concept so this is
more like a historical back test
we look to a live
test in production so i really put it
into the real world and see how it works
and then scale up
um
and just one note here with this um
uh the main challenge that we face
through this this whole process is
balancing the needs of whether it's a
project or whether it's a product and as
soon as you've got a real customer so i
said this is really beneficial but the
downside of that also is then you've got
somebody demanding something specific to
their data and it's very easy to quickly
build a project which is just about
their data and we're generalized to
another customer
and so talk about it more about that as
we go on
um
okay the building a team part of it um
so for us in in blyonda um a data
science team
um we really expect the data scientist
to be software engineers
they own the products
we'll have one team per product and
they'll really own it from a machine
learning perspective we expect them to
write production grade code
to deploy their own models
and to
fix production issues um model-based
ones you know not everything in the
world and then we of course create
barriers between the the customer and
the data science team so they're not
just getting bombarded um but we really
do like to keep our data scientists you
know
into the
uh involved with the real world um so
we're not uh prototypers who pass off
the code to another team to then
productionize
so that's when we when we have a new uh
product that we want to develop we build
a new team um because our existing data
scientists are busy on other products
um
okay let me talk a little bit about our
tech stack um
just looking at the time
so the um the tech stack of an
established blue under product first of
all so i just take one product as an
example it's called loom lip demand edge
this is our demand forecasting um
product
um
what are the uh what's the stack that it
uses
so for management of the the code um
we use git um but we use
an in-house built mono repo which we
call rack
and uh this is um
this provide well inside this there are
many different python packages sub
packages to it and we built this a few
years back uh for the purpose of sharing
code more easily across different
projects across different customers
and
it provides with it a common development
environment so everybody will be working
in the same docker environment
and it removes the issue
of
having a requirements uh hell
if you have lots and lots of different
um python packages all deployed
independently then very quickly you get
into a tricky situation where they're
not compatible with one another so
having it in this one monorepo with the
unit tesla joined up we find uh is a is
a very good way of sharing code across
the different uh products
uh also coming for free with that are
some jenkins pipelines so you get ci cd
for free uh when when you use this um
then for compute and storage resources
we use azure
uh but we orchestrate this through a
platform again internally developed
called stratosphere um which provides us
an api and a ui so as a data science
team we've really got at our fingertips
the ability to spin up resources um very
flexibly um and collect resources into
what we call a project
which are then associated to each other
in a nice neat way so it's just a way of
making it a lot more efficient way to
use the the azure resources
for data management we've got a
input api
that the customer delivers the data
through we've got
it goes into a database so interacts
assault but currently in the process of
migrating things to using snowflake
um and then the data scientists use
what's called carter tech so this is
data sets in blob storage basically so
this lets
us
break the bottlenecks of the database so
it lets you access uh data in parallel
and at scale through blob storage
from a machine learning perspective
we've got the uh
we use algorithm called cyclic boosting
um which is like a turbocharged uh
generalized linear model um i'd have
time to go into this but felix wick's
given some good talks on this in the
past that you can print
um we use mlflow for tracking um
experiments we use task for
parallelization
we've got a internal flask api for
triggering modeling jobs
and we use airflow for scheduling
so
yeah it's hard to give a very brief
overview of such a large stack that you
can see
all of these
um a mature product has has
these
behind it
and so when we go to start a new product
uh move into the next slide
um we really look to utilize as much of
that as possible right from the get-go
um so everything which i mentioned there
on day one of starting new team new
product development um we've got all of
our workflows in place
around the code decided by rack uh we've
got ci cd for free
um we can spin up resources straight
away uh really easily with with azure
and
stratosphere
um
we've got all this modelling stuff at
our fingertips that we can just
basically
port over from our existing products
um
and the main thing that we don't have
because it's a new offering with
different data is we can't use this api
straight away so in this example i gave
through today we load the data from raw
csv files and we process them in memory
um and this is a big uh yeah mistake i'd
say already
uh this is what we did but one of our
learnings is
maybe not to do that in the same way
next time so i'll talk more about that
later
um additionally of course we use a lot
of jupyter notebooks um here because
it's a bit more exploratory as well um
uh yeah
okay so finally on to the last section
here so um
i started calling this project
development product development and and
in reality it's some sort of a
combination of the two
um so
yeah days one to sixty um is proof of
concept phase
so here what are our priorities um we
need to do an exploratory data analysis
uh really get to grips with the data
we need to define an internal data
schema for our data
and make the transformation methods to
take that raw csv data that they've
given us and map that
into our internal schema
and
yeah this is a very important step i'd
say
when
setting off with the ambition to have a
product rather than a project or bespoke
project
by defining this internal data schema uh
you make a
clear distinction that you are not
wanting to build it for this one
customer otherwise throughout your code
you're gonna have customer specific
column names customer specific quirks
everything
uh just embedded in everything that you
do
we also require high code quality
standards so for unit testing and
as if it's production code right from
the start
um
and uh yeah we
process it once and put it in common
blob storage this is crucial the whole
team is working on the same data
then next we build a simple model um
nice and quick
and then uh
importantly there's step four uh really
define a shared modeling framework for
the team so uh make sure that everybody
is doing
that we've got the same definition of
better
that if everybody's in their own
notebooks and you've got different you
don't have a common evaluation framework
it's very hard to
understand really
compare one person's experiment to
another um
and uh yeah another key thing that we do
here is we embed the model evaluation
into the gate process so merging to
master will be blocked unless a common
baseline model is
explicitly updated so
what this means is
um
we have our current
best model and for someone to improve on
it they need to update that in the code
explicitly and we as a team are all on
the same page about uh about that that
update and
[Music]
okay so outputs from phase uh
this proof of concept phase
um we need to have a very good
understanding of the data so in this
particular example that i'm going
through today lci
um really we could define a very simple
data model uh inventory and inventory
adjustments so really inventory is just
telling us what was the calculated
inventory known at any particular point
in time and pretty much all of the other
data fits into this one simple data
schema
inventory adjustments so there we're
talking about
sales would be an adjustment which uh
subtracts from the inventory an incoming
order would be one which adds to the
inventory
incoming
wastage would remove from it and so on
so all of our data just fits into these
two simple
schemas
and then important model features we've
got um the calculated inventory so what
is the inventory prior to our correction
it's obviously a very crucial input
and the amount of time since the last
full count was done
so uh for an inventory error you can
imagine over time
this error gets larger and larger and
due to more occurrences of events that
cause it to drift
and so this is our findings from
this first phase these two features are
key
um
we need to have a good understanding of
our target data
and we've got a code base to iterate
from so when we started off this section
we have nothing and at the end of it
we've got something to move forward from
and did we prove the concept um so now
we know that we can predict something
useful
and what we found was we can remove the
aggregate bias in the inventory so as a
whole across uh aggregating across all
products and locations uh
in some time range you can see that the
inventory is is out by some percentage
uh before the correction and afterwards
uh we've got it nicely aligning
but in addition to that we can improve
the accuracy of the lowest level to the
mid um by by more than 20
so
this lets us move on to the next um
section i see i'm running out of time
here a bit so much a little bit faster
um
so great we've
proved the concept uh we move into this
phase here
uh mumps
three and four
and so now we need to prove its value
and so things get very technical now um
so we had this nice phase where we're
doing model development and we're
exploring data and now we need to
productionize data pipelines uh this
triggers the major refactor of our
codebase one and a key point to take
here is while we are trying to make
decisions from the start that we are
building a product uh we know that we're
going to have to refactor things as we
learn along the way uh significantly so
this is unavoidable
um performance tasting uh performance
testing uh automated monitoring model
release strategy operations all of a
sudden things get very much in this
direction that we need to focus on
okay and then finally uh the pilot so
uh we're ready to go live on a customer
which means that we are actually
impacting their predictions on a uh
in a live setting on a daily basis
they're sending us data we're sending
them back predictions so suddenly the
game changes uh you can't freely merge
to your master branch anymore uh your uh
customer is pinging you with uh
requests for analysis and explanation
and uh and they start to roll in you
need to do hotfix123 and and it feels
futile to resist suddenly you're a
project and you're you're scrambling to
to react
um but in parallel to this we've got a
second stream that would go on uh you
have to divide the team somewhat to some
extent where you start your next major
refactor um so this is to be ready for
the next customers so all of the
customer specific stuff that's snuck
into our code base we need to then uh
start refactoring out again even with
the best intentions these things go in
and you need to be ready to scale up uh
to other customers your current customer
post the pilot
so
post this period here we need to um
to scale
so what's next on this particular
example so today we are we are literally
here so we're near the end of this pilot
um and what we're thinking about now is
okay we need to formalize our input
output api um and that triggers our next
major refactor so integrating
uh the modeling workflows into snowflake
so as i said we went down this route of
processing the data
uh ourselves manually in part k files
and this is a uh
became a rabbit hole something which
would make a different decision from the
start if we could um but to move on to
the next phase we'll be um
migrating it to snowflake
[Music]
and just to summarize the wins and the
fails that we experienced in this last
six months so this example i walk you
through
um we went from concept to production in
just a few months this was a huge win
uh you don't get this without if this is
the first development you're trying to
do so we could only do this because
we're piggybacking off of our existing
products and our existing platform
that's in place for them so the uh the
this was
a nice achievement you can do this in
that time
we form a new team this is not to be um
underestimated how hard it is to to get
a new team together and to come up to an
efficient
standard
and we've got some promising early
results which i mentioned so the
med improvement 20 but there's lots to
learn and lots to generalize
the biggest fails are yeah from a data
engineering perspective you just
shouldn't uh
you make this decision early on the
data's small we can deal with it in
memory and you regret it
when down the line uh your board is
completely full of data engineering
stories and performance as your
bottleneck
um
and uh yeah i don't have time to go into
this actually so i can see where i'm
already a couple of minutes over so
um just to summarize so uh yeah find
yourself a suitable problem this
requires industry experts this isn't
something you can just do as a data
scientist
get yourself an enthusiastic customer uh
prove the concept prove it in practice
and then really for it to be a product
you need to be able to do this about
five more times so nothing's a product
until you've actually got several
several customers onto it
um and the biggest learning that we've
made in beyond over the years is that
you need to build on your experiences
build up your platform in a way such
that your next developments can uh
immediately take advantage of all of the
the things that translate across
products um and uh and set out from the
start if you want it to be a product
with product development standards um
because there's no going back from it if
you don't uh
unless you've you can just start from
scratch to the end and redevelop
your products completely from scratch
after you've done a few products
projects but
um
yeah that's it sorry for running over by
a couple of minutes uh thank you any
questions
oh no yes we've got one from anna how
many people were working on the product
especially data science
dot scientists machine learning
engineers and software engineers
so we
are a cross-functional team um where
some people do lean a little bit more in
one direction or the other of those that
are listed out there
but we do expect everybody to pretty
much be able to do anything everything
within the team there
but we on this project were product
project i can never get it right it
really is both
we were seven
people over the last six months
so this allows some degree of
parallelization between uh the
ad hoc things that pop up um and you
need to hop fix and react to for your
current customer
and the longer term goals of
uh and then taking a step back from what
you're doing day to day and actually
getting ready for the next customers or
uh further generalizing aspects of it
all right uh
that's the end of the question sir uh
thank you very much adam for being
for your giving your presentation and uh
you and everyone else are
free to
engage further in
our talks channel and slack
and uh this is the end of the session
but we'll have
a number of other ones coming up and uh
uh y'all y'all have a great day
yes thank you very much have a nice
friday